let's get started welcome uh uh to day
two of the uh Tony potassium
Extravaganza and birthday celebration
uh uh the first Speaker today will be uh
sambus uh go ahead Sam thanks thank you
for coming on this rainy day especially
because you could have stayed at home
with a cup of coffee and streamed me
uh yeah so that's a great pleasure to be
here a great honor to speak for Tony who
it's hard to believe we were all
reaching these ages of round numbers
um I'm past these ages so that's okay
um so I thought I'd talk about extended
frago proofs because that's something
Tony and I worked on together and I
thought oh we don't know much about
extended fragrant groups I can easily
mention all results we know about
extended fragrant proofs in 30 minutes
and stop early and then I got into it I
realized we actually know quite a bit
about extended fragrance so what that
means is I have a lot of slides so if
you don't want me to go too fast ask
questions I promise to at least put
every slide on the screen for a couple
seconds so then you can go home and
squeeze and see what I would have said
had I had time so ask questions
um
I can make the slides available too and
I'll correct them before I put them on
my web page too
okay well no I do that I'm good about
that stuff so
um and as I said you know we're all
reaching this age and I reached it some
five years ago I turned 60 and Tony
spoke for an event for me then and on a
similar Topic in fact she also thought
well what have I worked on directly with
Sam and strangely it's just the same
thing I haven't worked on joint with her
and so we had a lot of overlap in the
talk and she very kindly sent me your
slides I think I can just give you user
slides
so well okay so I I didn't but you know
what I what I remembered most about her
slides of what she sent them to me was a
couple pictures so the first one was was
this one
because I remember being befuddled at
and then someone explained that it was a
deer caught in the headlights of a car
like you're at the at a talk about your
own 60th birthday and I hope Tony
doesn't feel this way but you did a good
job of matching how life and fell down
so okay so there's
that was you okay I wasn't sure oh that
was you well it was me now
okay I thought it was me then too
oh I see it's different so she was
making the point of yes that she when
she was studying with Steve that she had
the big learning experience I guess and
all these things to learn like all of us
now so anyway then I I didn't steal any
20 slides but Demetri and Anastasia very
quietly bought me one of their nice
ticks pictures which I modified slightly
here's a bunch of systems that were on
their slides and what I'm going to say
is in particular I'm going to talk about
extended fragrance which is not on this
slide but if you look
now it is
and so it sits up here and
um this so this talk is this part up
there with the red part around extended
Fray and I thought well I'm just talking
about a little bit of Tony's work
because everywhere there's a red
exclamation mark Tony's done really deep
important work so I could have talked
about any of these topics and I hope
other people and plus there's all the
stuff she's done that isn't on these
pictures at all so there's lots of
things one could talk about but anyway
if I'm doing extended figure today
so let's go for it
uh just to remind you I think everyone
knows this stuff in the audience but if
not you're welcome to ask questions
um fragrant proofs are the usual
textbook proof system for propositional
logic we're proving things about Boolean
formulas variables range over true false
we have connectives like and or not
different if then and so forth and we
can formulate it with just modus ponens
as the only ruled inference extended
fragrant proofs introduce the extension
rule which lets you introduce an
abbreviation using a new variable P for
any formula that you wish right okay
well shouldn't involve P for instance
but okay and so in effect lines in an
extent of fragrant proof can be viewed
as Boolean circuits as compared to lines
in a fragrance new display formulas so
reasoning with Boolean circuits so we
want to look at the proof complexity of
extended fragrance so let's start from
the beginning here
okay so
oh
um actually yes I meant to put some more
arrows on here which I guess is my first
correction on my slides or something
like that right
oh okay so I think external Prager
simulates all these systems I guess
including SOS they're they're blowing on
this thing and it simulates all script
systems you have more balance boards as
far as I know okay but it definitely
simulates all these things that are
lower than it on the slide okay good
so
so going back to the very beginning uh
extended fragrant was introduced in the
form of extended resolution
oh geez what's wrong with your slides
are falling off the bottom um Extended
resolution by Satan in a 1966 St
Petersburg seminar
um and he had the the resolution rule
which in the English translation this
paper is called the annihilation Rule
and the extension Rule and he gave
exponential or balance on tree-like
resolution and regular resolution using
what we now call the site in principle
but for grid graphs so this is a
rectangularly arranged points in the
plane
okay good so that was the start actually
a pretty strong start they must say okay
right so good and then uh then the sort
of the Heyday The Glory Days of extended
rep resolution perhaps were of those uh
Steve Cook and Robert rackel and also
Rick also Rick statman proved a whole
bunch of stuff about extended Fraga so
first of all this is where they
formulate in terms of the extension rule
with Prego groups instead of resolution
groups there's equivalent strength but
now we allow connectives and or not if
then I believe that was original this
group
um if someone knows otherwise please let
me know uh we heard already about the
cook program if that's what it was
approving P naught equal to MP oh sorry
and T not equal to co-emp
um uh recal and his thesis gave the very
detailed proof for Fraga but not so hard
proof for extended Fraga that it doesn't
matter what propositional logic language
are used so we might as well use and or
not and if if then
there was the development of the PB
equational theory of bound and
arithmetic and the provably total
Universal formulas in this language have
polynomial size extended fragrance and
PV proves the consistency of extended
Prego and this is the strongest system
which PV proves consistency of
um
and then there was the characterization
of the proof size measured in number of
symbols for extended fragrant proofs
this polynomially related to the number
of proof lines in a fragrant proof so
basically the idea is just if you
Unwound all those definitions inherent
in the extension rule the number of
lines would be bounded in a fragile
proof would be bound by the size of the
extended fragrant proof and conversely
you only if you have a fragor proof with
humongous lines you could just introduce
abbreviations for the sub formulas
everything present and you get an extent
of failure proof with short formulas and
maybe most famously for the theorem
proving group here and many many more
bounds polynomial size proofs of a
visual principle
so that was that's that
um like I said questions are welcome
did not I'll just make it through the
whole talk in time
um
yes but that was um six six seven years
later okay I'll come up on it later yeah
that was my theory but yes six or seven
years later
okay so yes but so there's also
polynomial size groups in fragrance with
a different proof and that's sort of
relevant right okay so
so just jumping forward a little bit in
time just because this is supposed to be
a conference for Tony's birthday here
but not just because also a beautiful
result uh Tony and Aleister urquhart
introduced or to study the uh the
highest calculus which we heard a little
bit about already was already an
existing system a proof system that were
for a non-deterministic procedure for
generating
graphs which are not three colorable and
it generalizes to other values of three
uh K greater than three right but but
here it is for three there is the
following rules uh the complete graph on
four vertices is not three colorable and
there's a join Rule and the drawing rule
let me see if I can do this somehow
oh I see here we go
um
so the join rule here you start with two
graphs G1 and G2 and they have an edge
which I've drawn red and blue there and
another one that's red and orange but
sorry blue and red here I guess then
blue and orange here and then you
amalgamate them by identifying the blue
vertices which don't have to have the
same colors I'm just looking at the
pictorial things and putting a triangle
between the three vertices when you join
them together
so that's a join rule the idea being
that if G1 and G2 were both three
colorable then this Amalgamated G1 and
G2 is three three three colorable and
the contraction rule isn't
implicationally sound but it lets you
take
uh a graph of two distinct vertices
identify nodes in them
I really should have I read this paper
somewhat to prepare this talk but I
think I should go back and read it more
carefully really understand all this
stuff again but it's been a few years
and uh in particular if you drop rule
three you still have an implicationally
sound and complete system but possibly
rule three health so that very possibly
rule three helps and so
so the open question would have been uh
no it's the outstanding open question
was what's the shortest length or what's
an upper bound on the length of highest
calculus proof so three column three
callerability in the worst case
and so Tony and Aleister showed
I'm not of non-3 code yes so Tony and
Alistair showed that in fact the highest
calculus is polynomial equivalent to
Extended fragment uh and they did this
for tautologies and code appropriately
the non-free color ability
perhaps right and if you looked at the
the highest calculus without that on
that contraction rule that's
implicationally complete and it's piece
simulated by depth five fragrant groups
okay so that was two nice results in
particular as a corollary that ladder
system requires exponential size
derivations in the worst case because of
results due to Tony and a bunch of other
people starting with itai who always
seems to converse to be heard that
um that there's exponential lower bounds
on concept that fragrant groups for a
lot of things
and another follow-up result there was
that
um the tree-like highest calculus proof
requires exponential size
beautiful system what sort of wonders if
this could somehow be relevant for the
modern cdcl b-rant style things because
it's sort of similar improving
tautologies on graphs but I don't know
okay
so the highest calculus fruits use the
fact that the zero one substitution rule
is surprisingly powerful so if you start
with the fingerproof system with just
modus ponens not the extension Rule and
you allow a very simple substitution
rules you can replace a variable by a
constant uh then that's
equipment to extend the fragrance
I think that was a homework problem in
my Berkeley lecture notes uh presented
without proof and I think the way this
worked Tony can correct me Aleister
emailed me said can we use this result
and oh by the way what's the proof
so I guess you know suitably hard
homework problem but anyway there were a
lot of substitution results already
known
um let me get this
um
so in particular the substitution rule
was introduced by cooking recal uh or
actually introduced by Reagan himself
back in the 19th century in a stronger
setting uh and I was shown equivalent to
the substitution phrase you take Fraga
plus the substitution rule for General
formulas this was shown equivalent to
Extended for a goodbye uh One Direction
was shown by uh
spoken recal and the harder Direction
was proved separately by Martindale and
young project and Paula Whitlock right
and then zero one substitution Rule and
variable substitution rule um I think
showed up in my homework problems at
Berkeley eventually showed up in a paper
right okay uh one open question here is
does variable substitution as I defined
it allows identifying variables so you
could you could have a formula with X
and Y and it has two two variables and
substitute X for y thus identifying the
two variables if you don't allow
identifying variables as variable per
mutation we don't know whether that and
it's a phrase
Direction
yes that's something yeah maybe that's
sort of it yeah it's not real this is
I'm not sure how that belief system
that's a good question
but actually there's a more fundamental
question here to move on to the next
topic does the frag approved system all
by itself simulate extended pretty good
and so uh
Tony was uh as you heard already spent
three years I guess it was in San Diego
as a postdoc
um which she and Rich were there after
year through Ellen as well was there and
and uh but one of the things we worked
on uh with with Maria and Tony and I was
the lack of plausible
comatorial example separating praga from
extended frago right we have you know
it's just a strange thing you take P
versus MP we have tons of NP complete
things that could plausibly separate p
and NP and we just don't have much of
this or phrase versus extended Fraga and
so it's known that particularly the
consistency statements for extended
Fraga these are propositional formulas
that Express the planetary partial
consistency statement of extended Vega
those have short extended fragrance that
was due to Steve and they're complete
for the consequences of extended frag in
the sense that if a Fraga proves this
Theory or or weaker proof systems prove
these things in polynomial science that
P simulates extender frega but this
seems like a cheat right and so what
about commentatorial examples
and
we looked at a bunch of these things
first of all there were a couple already
known the pixel principle was already
known to have polynomial size groups in
both brain and extended Fraga and
likewise the Ramsey theorem was known to
be due to povel uh they have polynomial
size and Fraga and then I think Tony
really did the work for a lot of this
paper here she went out and asked a
bunch of people can you give me examples
of theorems that should be easy in
extended free again hard for fake and I
don't know how these people knew what
these things were but they kind of had a
bunch of great examples and uh we credit
them in a paper but we didn't put anyone
as co-authors so
but uh the oddtown theater and Grand
pawley Theater where you see all the
things in blue I might highlight
especially the a b equals I implies ba
equals I these are for
Square
zero one matrices
uh I was actually didn't show up on our
paper this came later from Steve Cook so
these are all these linear algebra based
uh things where the obvious proofs or
the not so obvious groups have linear
algebra in them right and then there are
a few things that are combinatorial
Frankel's theorem I put in red because
it was exactly the kind of thing we're
looking for we if we had polynomial size
extended finger proofs we couldn't make
polynomial size breaker proofs so thus
it was at the time a candidate for
separating the two systems
and other ones like Bondies and
crossovertona we started them with the
candidates but then they turned out we
found following his eyes greater groups
so they weren't candidates anymore and
other people suggested other things uh
knees or lovash uh version of the Tucker
Lemma local Improvement principles came
out of studies and bound arithmetic
these also generated examples right
interests of time I'm not going to
mention them but they are so the outcome
was possibly disappointed disappointing
is that all the linear algebra things
have quasi polynomial size fragor proofs
to start off with so this was due to uh
rubus and sound or a building on earlier
work of Sam rather cook
Frankel's theorem uh James Eisenberg a
student of mine and uh Maria
um
the air but anyway I don't know what
that thing is doing I'll fix that later
has polynomial sized fragrance or lovash
and Tucker likewise and most of local
Improvement principles
Bell either firmly in the frago camp or
not seeming to have extended fragrant
fruits at all there's a few cases left
but basically we covered nearly
everything that we know right so and
just
the other thing was coming back to the
pigeon principle this is one of our
starting points was that one of the
reasons we believe frag is different
than the extent of craigo was that the
Steve and Robert recalls proof of the
pigeon principle didn't work
in Frank it was very special to extend
him very good but then I was able to
prove not too long ago that in fact if
you take their original proof it can be
recast as a fragrant proof that same
construction with quasi-polonial size
proofs so again we had this sort of
Quasi polynomial separation is the best
we can concretely give
um so summary here a We Believe extended
fragus should be stronger than Frank if
we lack good examples
and B I spent fair amount of time trying
to show that Fraga could quasi-polarly
simulate extended very good all about
success so
yes is there any known something like
you know if you close this and he's not
able to see it oh yeah that's a perfect
question I didn't ask this that's not in
the slides also so one might say is
there some connection between the
question of whether Boolean formulas
polynomially simulate Boolean circuits
and the question of whether Fraga is the
same as extended fragrance we don't have
any such you know the patient either way
it could be the formulas capture the
strength of circuits but that can't be
proved in a phrase system and so you
don't get the stimulation and conversely
it could be that you know extended
fragrant Foods could be simulated or
plots like polynomially stimulated by
fragrant fruits which by some mechanisms
other than
uh translating circuits to foreign
formulas
how about it intuitively like absolutely
that's our motivation is that somehow
formulas or we think less expressive
than all the size circuits and so that
you should be able to reason with more
Concepts and thus proven more things but
it's just a wishful thinking
so while we're asking about examples
um
what about the insurance table formula
so those are not combinatorial enough to
be good candidate separating principles
well but actually good point truth table
or formula form on my so the question
was not about separate with two table
formulas um that was not on my radar and
I don't know the answer to that question
but uh maybe someone else will comment
on that okay
it's easy for extended freaking hard for
free I'm not I'm not aware of any true
say well I wanted to do that but I
haven't really thought about it
okay
that we
don't know the history I have a feeling
it was first done by which of the papers
try check or
so if you go very quickly because I'm
getting a little bit towards the end of
time uh slots and times up so yarn show
jump yarn
check show that tree like extended Vega
is pulmonally equivalent to monitorial
like extended frago uh Neil toppen
mentioned in this talk uh recently that
tree like there's a tree-like sequence
calculus G1 with Quantified
propositional logic involving only
existentially Quantified formulas and
that's equivalent to Extended Fraga uh
and that by the way has very close
connections to the bounded arithmetic
Theory S12 right and so I'm going to
move on
uh Jeremy avigod gave an interesting uh
result that he has some plausibly hard
comatorial topologies T which are
equivalent to the consistency of
extended fragrant proofs so um I don't
believe anyone's ever been able to
follow up on this before the results but
it's it's an interesting result and they
deserves being looked at again
um again I haven't looked at these quite
a few years but they're based on
topologies about hereditarily finite
sets
um moving along then we have maybe more
relevant well I wanted to cover here two
conditional hardness results so cry
check and putlocks show that the crypto
system RSA is computationally secure
then extended fragrant does not have
feasible interpolation people talked
about interplay I think Maria will talk
about interpolation more tomorrow so
I'll let her take this subject on uh
also she and Tony and Ron Ross extended
this to integer factorization being hard
and that assumption uh systems such as
Fraga and tc0-frego that's accounting
version of Fraga also don't have
feasible interpolation and there's
another result that also applies to ac03
as well I'm sure that's involved
so these kind of results block some of
our known more balancing methods I
should have said they're not lower
bounds lower bound methods right
uh another result which Colleen was also
involved was uh census with uh
novemakovich myself and Tony is if
p is not equal to NP there's no
polynomial time algorithm that
approximates the length of the shortest
proof in the proof system Q to within a
factor of 2 to the log angle one minus
Epsilon it's a factor of that you know
and so where Q can be it's not really a
theorem about extended fragrant but I
still put it in because it does apply to
Extended fragrance because Q can be any
of these systems I've listed here
including rather weak systems like
resolution right so so that's another
thing akin to insert in interpolation
um then there's I think again I think
this would be covered a lot has been
covered already in a couple talks you
all could talk about it earlier for
cutting planes on the spectral account
on other talks in the meeting here cdcl
uh conflict driven Clause learning
solvers their most successful methods
for satisfiability
um these modern solvers use this sort of
non-implicational reasoning they infer
formulas that don't follow logically
from the assumptions uh a simple example
would be pure literal inference where if
a literal occurs only positively you can
assume it's true without loss of
generality but there's more complex ones
as well there's a variety of systems
that have names like BC for Block Clause
rat for resolution asymmetric topology
PR for propagation redundancy and so on
there's the deletion version where you
stick a d on the front these things are
all known to be polynomial equivalent to
Extended Fraga and they hold out the
hope that maybe we can get some of the
power of extended Fraga implemented
efficiently effectively and to good to
do good results in cdcl
um so far it's most more of a hope
although there's been some isolated
successes I must say satisfaction driven
Clause learning has um
enable been very successful at finding
more or less optimal proof proofs of the
original principle of the more or less
optimal and I don't know if it's optimal
or not but the best I know is n cubed
and these kind of things and that's
about what they get in practice albeit
it takes exponential time to find the
fruits of length and Q but still a good
step and succeeds for pigeons up to
systems with over 50 pigeons which is
remarkable right without this it's like
13 digits and then you hit a big wall uh
and I was actually small Jacob last week
mentioned the maxsat systems uh Maria
and I and other co-authors have worked
on maxat methods and achieved similar
success visual principles solving
digital principle up to about 50 plus
pigeons right a nice looking growth rate
and so on and Jaco pointed out that it's
still the the way these Max solvers work
at least some of them it is a form of
extension that's going in under the hood
inside the max stats solver so that's an
interesting observation
okay
anyway you have interesting time I'm
going to end up with one set of results
also that Tony was involved in
um
the ideal proof system somehow I
shouldn't go so close to the top and
bottom of my slides there okay we'll
have to have to slide around
um so this was Josh grochow and Tony
placi worked on just in the last few
years this is a static algebraic proof
system where an IPS proof is an
algebraic circuit meaning in this case
let's just think over the over the reels
but with constants for zero one such
that c of inputs X and a vector of zeros
evaluates to the zero polynomial and C
of the same X and then a vector or
polynomials evaluates to one so this is
a proof that the F's can't all be
simultaneous equal to zero
okay and it's not quite a quick recal
system because it uses a randomized
polynomial time verification algorithm
sort of a deterministic one but close
enough and so it's a polynomial identity
testing or Pit and the theorem here is
that IPS polynomately stimulates
extended fragate was on my picture from
the beginning right
and uh how is this relevant otherwise
for extended fragrance is
If instead of Fraga proves the
correctness of the so-called pit axioms
quote unquote for some polynomial size
Boolean circuits so let me say if we
know there's a randomized poll
algorithm then there's polycy circuits
so if we could somehow identify those
polycline circuits well the dumb thing
to do would be to stick axioms into
extended Vega to say these circuits are
correct but the better thing to do is to
to use some very minimal set of axioms
which they identified and then said If
extend a frag approves these minimal set
of axioms about pit evaluation circuits
then extended Fraga is polynomial
equivalent to IPS and these minimal sets
of axioms are written at the bottom of
the slide rather small print because
you're not really expected to understand
them on the fly but let me just say that
very Loosely uh the first Axion says if
you substitute a zero polynomial for the
uh I'm sorry if you substitute a
constant into the zero polynomial it's
still the zero polynomial
the second one says that us you can't
have both a circuit Computing but that's
the one whole the one polynomial and the
zero polynomial at the same time uh by
which I mean c and one minus C are both
zero the third one says if you
substitute a zero polynomial for a
constant zero appearing in a zero
polynomial the result is a zero
polynomial
and the fourth one says if you permute
the variables of a zero polynomial it's
a zero polynomial
all pretty simple simplistic facts and
if you had those
action approval instead of frega that's
enough to bootstrap your way up to
Extended pretty good is equivalent to
IPS yeah that's a good question it would
suffice to prove it in S12
um
yeah if the circuits were uniformly
generated you could prove this in S1 too
right I mean
what's up
it's kind of job
so if you prove these axioms
it's better to prove it in advance yeah
so if you can prove S12 and of course
the the sort of first idea here would be
well there's there's a circuit there's a
randomized circuit that computes this
with high probability so if you set the
constants correctly
you have a circuit right then how do you
set the constants correctly that's
probably some kind of counting or even
so you're probably pulling in the meat
pigeon principle so you're probably
sitting at t22 it's an S12 and I have no
idea what that would do to any of this
stuff if that worked if that worked
is
I don't know usually it's better to
prove something interesting
so the problems I don't think people can
hear it problems that's better to prove
things in S12 then in an extended
fragrant because a you just give one
proof and you're done and B it's like
you've got more more conceptual things
you can reason with it's often easier to
reason than this one too than
propositional logic that's kind of and
Tony's work for instance so Samsung yeah
yeah if if pit is provably in P yeah
that's one two then this certainly works
yeah
yeah you still need the approval to get
extended rate equal to IPS you need the
provably part because it could be
provably it could be true but since
Santa Fe doesn't prove it they can't
still dance yes
and uh and then the other thing that
came out of whoops oh boy
okay
[Laughter]
pretty much out of time so if the other
thing that was that uh Tony and her
co-authors showed that yeah
um IPS has not polynomly bounded then p
is not equal to vnp another way to say
is the permanent doesn't have polynomial
size algebraic circuits which is
conjecture that they're unequal as far
as I know but it's also viewed as a very
hard problem to solve right so uh as a
corollary if the extent of Craig has
political size the pit axioms or the
type we just discussed
and if extended frag is not pulmonally
bounded then we need to use on equal to
VMP
and why is that relevant that's my last
slide here it is uh Tony and Josh argued
this may explain why lower balance burst
out of Trigger or it's harder to obtain
because they would apply all sorts of
resolving problems no very hard problems
great circuits okay if I'm on this stage
or stuff
oh good okay
um I mean the other possibility I guess
is that it just you could just show the
pit accidents
okay but it's still gets a connection
acting it's not very good and now you
seem like
thank you
happy birthday
wonderful uh Sam uh so uh we have time
for questions we've had uh this is uh
there are a lot of questions I think uh
even more than we have answers
old phones Behavior solvable
so like one was uh about permanent yeah
adding permutation substitution
and then the other one is uh maybe you
didn't mention it but lower size bounds
for like figure percent I think you have
the best results there oh do you know if
that's uh those are still the best so
this the theorem is
um you can get quadratic lower bounds on
the number of symbols and frago or
extent of fragor proof of some rather
dumb formulas of the form
no so the false sand bolts and bolts and
volts
or true nested from with the or true
down the bottom and so the trouble is
the shortest proof of that has to unwind
that formula to get to the true so that
takes in Fraga you have a minimum of N
squared symbols in the proof and that's
our best more battle number symbols in
Fraga and the same thing we should hold
for I guess for extended well for
extended frame you're actually going to
prove that formula you've got to form it
so it also take sensors so like CNS
there's no
or small with CNS for instance nothing
is no right yeah
some sort of linear side so basically
you have to look at every sub formula of
the formula you're proving
and that was also the type of method
that we used for the paper on the
hardness of finding the shortest
groups so these things had simple very
simple slightly longer proofs the
question is whether the shorter proof
that takes advantage of a small minimum
satisfying assignment so you've unwind
the less of a formula to get those or
trees
after you basically kill the most of
your own candidates for separating free
game extended frigate what's your
intuition your current iteration about
what the principles should have to be a
viable candidate
so that's a good question I mean what
what should accept separate fragrant
from extended prayer I mean I'm lacking
good examples and which makes me nervous
and so maybe I still think that maybe we
should go back and someone else more
confident that they should try to prove
that very good performance polynomically
stimulates the extent of breakups so one
thing that the approach I took was the
the second proof of the pigeon principle
that first prove it has polynomial size
and almost 30 years later right fruit
had quasi-poland wheel size and still
managed to get the worst result
published 30 years later
but the point was this the second proof
used St connectivity and graph
reachability and graph some the idea
would be maybe a short extent of
fragrant proof there's some sort of
property about reaching paths through
the extent of Fraga proof that you could
somehow say a short extended fragrance
proof is proving more than just the
formulas true it's something about the
structure of the sub formulas or
something of that type but I never get
make it work so it seems I mean I didn't
read the police but it seems that the
most of these examples are really Nancy
too or many of these examples
so it was a polynomial maybe it's not so
yeah yeah so so yeah I didn't say this I
meant to say earlier the the linear
algebra examples all depend on
determinants and determinants are
computable nc2 and what who was in
samrats showed was that in fact the
properties of determinants could be
expressed and proved
in a breaka system using quality polymer
size groups using nc2 definitions
so
Robert
okay yeah and so I asked my questions
about this
the axioms actually so I mean maybe you
can do it in S12 but maybe if you put
the system with like some sort of
approximate counting like in APC or
something yeah maybe APC or APC ABC one
or two might be able to do that
um I said t22 earlier but they can see
one or APC two are contained in that
theory and yeah maybe they could prove
the existence of circuits for pit
polynomial size but I don't see so then
okay good question maybe something like
Emerald UF could could simulate IPS that
are not occurred negative four
right now
I don't think we know how to show that
easy peace for it
even if people
requires algebraic properties of course
right yeah versus the Swarm super Lemma
which I don't think is formalizable at
this moment okay so Albert's comment
says people maybe can't hear it online
is the shorts zipple them is required
for the proof of pit being having
poly-sized circuits and we don't know
how to formalize this at the moment
okay well thanks for thank you for
wonderful talk and a great conversation
the